welcome everybody to our lovely lovely
panel called creating dance virtually
we have some wonderful uh student
performers
and our dance lecturer uh and news for
music and theater arts um
but we're going to want to let everybody
know that we are recording the session
so that um this can be uh viewed
asynchronously so if you would not like
to be on video feel free to
mute your video so you're not recorded
um
thank you thank you all panelists for
being here um we're to go ahead and go
and start
with faraz and ani and then we're going
to go to joy
and then we're going to go to dan and
then we'll do a question and answer
afterwards
where we'll ask you to put questions in
the chat
and then we'll go from there so let's
start with for roz and ani
cool uh yeah so ani and i are going to
be talking about creating dance
virtually uh you want to take it away
yeah sure
so basically who are we faraz was
a an mn student in 63 last year and
i am currently a junior in 5 7 which is
biochemistry
and we've basically been dancing since
our freshman years
um so we we both started off dancing on
mirchi
and from there we both ended up moving
on and also dancing on redonkulous
and movementality um redonkulous is the
top left
movementality is like the top middle one
and mitchie's the one in the red and
this last picture here
is um for us choreographed to dance for
dance troupe which is you know like the
big
big dance program at mit and i was in
this dance as well
along with a lot of our friends
and um basically before kovid here's
just some of
our performances just a quick cut of all
that
yeah so this is just uh just to show
relative comparison but
about a minute
[Music]
me
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
baby girl we can't pretend let's pump
and grind
because tonight will never end let me
take you down
i really wanna take you down
[Music]
oops sorry yeah so those were basically
some of the
some things that we've been on in some
performances that we've been a part of
um
and now i guess we'll get to the point
where we talk about uh how things have
changed
since everything sort of went online
we're going to be talking about a piece
that we created
um and a showcase that has been hosted
by move mentality both during
both basically and mid april and then
also kind of
briefly touching on logistics of dancing
especially going into the fall of this
year um
so back uh after we got kicked off of
campus
um after like a couple of weeks uh any
and i
got on a zoom call and we're like hey
you know things are crazy um and ani
shaved his head
his head which is really crazy um and i
guess this sort of interaction inspired
us
to create like a concept video around
this where uh even though we're all sort
of separate uh we're trying to find ways
to still stay connected
um and so basically on the right there's
like a
screenshot of the art zoom call where
his head is shaved and then on the left
is kind of part of the concept video
where
uh that point is kind of conveyed and
we'll show up a larger
longer clip of this later um so some of
the challenges
that we faced um with this online format
is that over zoom you know the audio
usually
i mean it's not synced up so trying to
choreograph and collaborate is pretty
difficult
um and i guess the concept that we were
trying to do was like a zoom call
dance video and so we had like a
restricted space and we had to dance
mostly with our hands which is something
that we're not
really used to and uh another question
is how do we showcase this because
um you know usually redoculus for
example hosts a showcase called footwork
in the spring which unfortunately got
uh cancelled but more on that later and
but some of the benefits of this format
are that you can have different
takes and and put together different
sections and you can have interesting
screen formational ideas have different
backgrounds different props etc
to convey your ideas um so to talk about
a little bit more about
the showcase aspect so movementality
decided
uh basically to host a showcase in
mid-april kind of around the same time
the footwork was supposed to happen
as a way to try to try to get the dance
community together
um so on the left you can see there's a
zoom call here uh
where everyone's sort of watching and uh
here on the right is the facebook event
um some of the challenges with
organizing this was you know first
deciding
whether we wanted to do it live or
pre-recorded uh we ended up going with
pre-recorded just because it was
logistically easier and having like a
youtube playlist
um then we have to figure out like how
who has the best you know ping and
reliable video playback and
how do we deal with the audience
response while the video is being played
um but then some of the benefits are
that you get attendance and submissions
from all over the country
um so you like a lot of people show up
from like west coast and stuff um and
one thing that's really fun is because
people aren't actually performing live
um it makes it more natural to just
immediately discuss
pieces that have been played with the
actual choreographers and what their
idea was going into it
and there's also pretty wide diversity
in pieces that were actually played
so now i'm going to show like a few
different clips from
the first mmtv event
and basically the intro to show some
clip with that
bunker i submitted and part of longer
clip that of our video as well
i think we're ready to begin move
mentality tv's
first ever digital dance show
[Music]
i reach out to you but my hands can't
hold enough
enough of your greatness
you teach me patience
but the best of our
[Music]
hey it's a blessing that you're in my
life
make me look even better when we shall
we shine together
yeah that's what love is
now
[Music]
yeah so that was a clip of that and we
can discuss more
you know questions at the end if you
have any um but
yeah so now ani's going to talk a little
bit about the logistics uh especially
this fall
yeah so um you know since the fall is
all online
the dance teams basically have to find a
way to accommodate that
and what we've realized is that social
media
is probably the most impactful way to do
so um
basically like you pub your upcoming
events keep track of who your officers
are
and yeah basically just just get all
your information out there
and um and some of the more specific
challenges are
like auditions so in the past you know
you teach auditions to
um you teach them live and basically
watch everyone live as well and discuss
later by recording however that's not
possible anymore so
that that's one of the main issues um
another one is
uh like we discussed earlier just
choreographing and learning choreo
without synced audio
and so you can't ask questions and a lot
of those features are basically gone
but some like some of the benefits
involve um
just being able to combine different art
forms now so from like video editing to
graphic design
dance and music everything just comes
together and you're able to find new
ways to express yourself
artistically and another aspect is just
like maybe thinking about dance in a new
way so instead of focusing on
choreograph
choreography and teaching maybe focus
more on training fundamentals and
improving
as dancers and just growing so it's just
a time to reflect on our abilities and
our um
our goals and maybe approach dance in a
different way
yep so that's basically all we have um
we have
links i think this slide will be sent
out anyways but we have links to
different teams instagram handles and as
well as some of the
longer versions of the videos that we've
played but yep
[Music]
all right thank you any and um if you
guys have any questions feel free to put
them in the chat we'll talk about it
after all our speakers have
have given their presentations joy come
on
up hello can everyone hear me
am i good okay um so i'm joy i'm
in the class of 2022 and i'm majoring in
6 14 and 18 with a minor in music
so i'm already involved in like a lot of
art stuff on campus just besides dance
um but we're here to talk about dance so
i did not have a presentation
like on him for us but um
i was just going to like kind of show
you some videos and talk about my what
my dance team asian dance team does
so i'm the director of public relations
so i'm on the exact team and i'm also a
traditional choreographer for
the asian dance team which is currently
the largest dance team on campus we had
over 260 members last semester
it was crazy um and overall just an
overview
we're focused on mostly traditional
contemporary asian dance as well as
modern asian pop so that includes k-pop
j-pop c-pop
all of that um and we are not only run
at mit in the undergraduate and graduate
communities but we also have friends
from harvard and from the greater boston
community who join us for our showcases
every semester
um and i think the thing that's most
unique about adt and also
i guess dt as part of it is um we're
very like very very beginner-friendly
and beginner welcome so we seek to
kind of create a space where beginners
um or like
people who just got into college and
want to try out dance can feel like safe
and welcomed at mit which i think is
really important
um and we also pride ourselves on being
kind of a social community
um so like creating friendships as well
as just being a dance group and helping
everyone improve their dancing ability
um this semester just like with the
virtual format
um a breakdown of what we're doing we
are doing
asynchronous rehearsals um so our
we probably will have some form of kind
of synchronous like zoom workshops every
week but
otherwise like all our rehearsals will
be uploaded online because so many of
our members
are in like a non-us time zone
which might make it hard for them to
attend synchronous rehearsals
in addition all of our um auditions
which are happening this weekend
are kind of like up to your own time so
we're sending out a youtube playlist
during the three hour audition time
window
of like kind of a workshop style like
slow choreo breakdown teaching
run through and they have the three
hours to kind of
work through those videos on their own
and send their filmed videos back to us
so that's what our audition is
consisting of
and we're also going to have like a lot
of choreographers on a zoom call with
breakout rooms
to kind of um help answer questions and
guide like new members or beginners
along the way
so that's kind of exciting and i will be
running
some of the audition shifts so if you
are coming into auditions i will be
there
say hi um so with that i was
going to kind of show you some things
that adc has done in the past
which are cool so let me share my screen
so this is before quarantine so adt
normally has a breakdown between
showcase and covers our showcases are
what can
um i i think we would consider it are
like normal adt
so these are just like one hour a week
very low time commitment practices and
in the
at the end of the semester we normally
put on a huge showcase normally in
masala
um and it's always like a very hectic
and good time and covers are more
um like a shorter time duration i would
say they normally take
four to five weeks and during those four
to five weeks it's
a lot more time commitment but the
result is a finished like very
nicely filmed and edited product that we
put on our youtube channel
so this preview i believe consists only
of covers but i will drop the link to
our showcase channel later in the chat
down
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
me
[Music]
ah
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Laughter]
um
[Music]
is
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]
down
yeah so those are a few snippets of some
of our covers if you
want to watch them in full um they're
also on the adt youtube channel
um and let's see lydia
yeah um miguel if you could show the
next video
i think lydia said there was some lag
there's another one it's the
dynamite challenge but i was going to
talk a little bit about it first
so this is what pre-covered adt looked
like
um super exciting and
after um
hang on okay wait i guess i'll answer
the question later right
i guess okay um so basically that was
pre-cop at adt
everything was very exciting um that we
had we always had a lot of projects
going on and after covet started
we kind of thought like what we could do
about this whole like distance situation
because we're not
used to like not being in the same room
obviously
so one thing that we did um
for last semester obviously we didn't
have a showcase because rehearsals
weren't able to continue but
we were able to do a really successful i
think we had like 200 something
attendees
we had an online premiere of our
showcase videos from fall 2019
and that was kind of like a showcase
because it was still like everyone's
together and we had it on youtube
um so everyone could like comment in
real time with each other
and that was really cute um and this
semester we have a full plan in place
again with the
kind of on your own time auditions and
then
um and then the asynchronous rehearsals
and we plan
on editing all the videos together for a
showcase
and we have both editors within our
community and we've also reached out to
some
like people skilled with video editing
outside of our communities
who are acting as like editing advisors
for our choreographers
so we're planning on doing a full set
list this semester nothing is changing
and um as of yesterday night we had
around
170 signups which is actually really
good considering that it's all virtual
so we're all really excited for that and
as part of our audition
kind of promo and pub process we put
together a fun video
using bts's dynamite which just released
it's like a huge deal right now it's
like number one on pop charts or
something
so that was a popular thing that we did
and miguel if you could share that
just so there's no lag
it's the second link in the email i sent
[Music]
you
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
uh
[Music]
we hope you enjoyed our small surprise
and now it's your turn to submit the
audition form
and join adt
um so as as i'm sure everyone has heard
from other dance teams like pupping is
definitely the most important part of
this process
um so yeah as the pub chair for adt i am
proud that we have
so many signups we actually made a bet
about it so
i thought we were going we weren't going
to get over 50.
um one of our captains said over a
hundred and the last captain was like no
i'm sure that we will have more than 150
and i lost the bet so i have to buy both
of them drinks now
but yeah that's all i have for adt so if
there are questions
awesome thank you joy um we're gonna if
you have any questions feel free to put
them in the chat
um we're gonna have dan talk and then
we'll answer all the questions in the
chat
dan hey um hi everybody
um first of all that's it's so amazing
to see all the work the dance teams are
doing that you all are making
and the videos it's it's super inspiring
um
and i feel like uh hard to follow so i
will do my best but we'll see what
happens
um i've been i'm a lecturer
in in movement and dance in theater arts
um
and i've been focused mostly on on what
i make
going how do you churn i like this idea
of how do you turn the scar
into a star so how do we take the
problem and turn it into an asset
and looking at how we can make dance
that is served by
this bizarre video
teleconference situation that we're in
and how we can
make things that are not trying to
approximate
what we would have done live but make
things that could only be done
um uh with with video
um i've been involved in a number of
projects oddly since
when when kovit hit i was i
was just about to start rehearsing a a
show i was choreographing a production
at bard college
and they immediately just switched it to
an online production so when i had one
rehearsal in person then everything
after that
was was virtual so i've been
getting a lot of experience making stuff
via zoom
and how to work asynchronously and how
to make stuff that will be effective for
a video format
and then i was really lucky to work with
this um
choreographer and filmmaker named
janessa clark who's a new york based
artist who has this project called
communion where
she's um getting different people to
film themselves dancing and then she's
compositing them
into duets and there's an artist named
uh noah sombra who's a montreal-based
choreographer and dancer who
he and i have been like sort of on each
other's radar for about 15 years and
i've wanted to work with him he's one of
my favorite
artists i've wanted to work with him
forever and
suddenly with this situation it was an
opportunity for us to make a thing
together
um so miguel if you want to roll that
video
of the duet of benoit and i this is just
a little bit of
a longer piece
[Music]
so
[Music]
so yeah you get the idea so yeah with
that project what we did was
um uh we both worked individually i
i went first filming and janessa set us
up in very specific ways like we made
parameters that worked
the camera was a certain height off the
floor and a certain height from the back
wall the back wall had to be white so we
could match them up
um we both improvised
to either um we did a bunch we both
improvised to
a bowie song or to eric saty and uh but
then cut the sound out
and then um i went fur and then while
watched mine and kind of made his a
response to mine
and then actually my video got messed up
so i had to make a response to benoit so
we kind of get like a
a back and forth to influence each other
um and then put all that together and
then
sent that and then janessa sent that off
to a composer who wrote brand new music
for it
that was really a process of like layer
upon layer upon layer upon layer upon
layer
and we found that that was actually a
way that we could work that would
like was only possible via via the
distance and the video and stuff
um and so i'm looking i'm really excited
about ways that we can keep exploring
that rely on the video as opposed to use
it as a as a hindrance
awesome thank you dan yes thank you
um so um feel free to continue adding
questions in the chat we're going to go
with some very specific ones first and
then we're going to go
to broader so a joy was the adt dance
team actually in downtown crossing in
boston
yes so our covers are filmed literally
all over the place um in boston
uh at mit sorry and just like
in the general boston cambridge area
we've traveled a long way for some of
them so
the dance that you saw i think was miro
it was actually in downtown crossing and
that was part of our k-pop and public
series
where it's like one take um just
somewhere
and we've also entered um some of our
covers in like
official big k-pop dance competitions
um so i remember we had one where we
filmed at four locations there was like
inside a t-stop
in boston um and downtown crossing
like in december when there were
christmas lights at night
um and a few other places and they're
all like really
cool the the one you saw that was on the
charles river that was on the dock
awesome and so also who does the styling
for your videos
uh who does the styling normally um in
the past we've
actually hired professional video
editors for some of our like bigger and
more time intensive covers
um in the pa we've also just had like
specific
cover directors and choreographers edit
their own videos
but they're all filmed and edited really
well i think
awesome um and so a great question was
posed
that with the time being and where
everybody doing on zoom
how do you manage synchronization issues
open to anybody
i can jump on that and then i would
welcome anybody to correct me or
or augment what i say i found that
starting to work and not being so
worried about synced up
is a great way to start just going like
we're just generating moves we're just
making stuff and we're allowed to get it
wrong
and then when you hit a certain point of
having to sync it up
at that point i rely on one person who i
if i'm choreographing
i kind of pick whoever's like nailing it
and go okay you record it and make a
video and then we're all going to
asynchronously
match up to your moves on this song and
learn it that way
so at least that way you can you're not
trying to get synchronous on a zoom call
you're doing it asynchronously and then
to be quite honest you just have to hope
that there's like
not awful latency issues if you're
performing it live or you can do it in
the edit if you're doing it not live
um but it's allowing it's allowing for
the problems to be there
until you need to pin it down has been
effective for me and i'd love to hear
other solutions
yeah so i think one thing um i've
experienced as well is like
i guess the asynchronous uh problem is a
problem but
if one person is also sharing their
audio like as
as if they're like playing the music for
everyone else
then at least for them like the audio
and the movement is synced up so then
you can have like one person sort of
lead it in a way um which
allows for some amount of
synchronization
yeah for us specifically um we split up
like sections of the song we wanted to
choreograph
and basically like you know he took the
first 20 seconds and then i took the
next 20 seconds and so forth
and then that way we were all we had
like our goals in terms of
the sections of the song and it was
easier to sync up that way
right yeah and when we were sort of
making our video i guess
we met up more to discuss like high
level ideas
like structural ideas um and then we
kind of split off to
to implement that like specific choreo
and stuff
um yeah in terms of the synchronization
i would just add a note um
like sometimes if your wi-fi is bad and
you share your computer video along with
the audio that actually makes the
synchronization worse
so it there's actually an option to
share computer audio only
and that will sync it up with whoever's
sharing this video
um so that works for zoom calls and also
when we're video editing
and everyone plays their own music there
is an option in the software we use
that like actually allows like automatic
synchronization of the different frames
um so that's really really handy so we
don't have to do it by eye
[Music]
awesome um we're gonna get a specific
one and i'm going to expand it just a
little bit
so dan how was the process for
choreographing the duet
and editing the film like and then i
also want to hear from joy
and from raza anakin how you guys deal
with video editing
dan um for that project i actually
didn't do the edit uh janessa whose
project
is did the edit um a lot of it was about
scale
and make because we had the body
separately we had to make sure
the parameters of filming were nailed
down so that
like um like we actually measured on the
wall and showed where six feet was at
one point
um i'm a little taller than benoit so
it's like we wanted to get
our actual heights even and then you can
kind of let the camera roll from there
but a lot of it was all about setup
beforehand and allowing
for um like allowing for as much
variation
in the movement as possible but in
really strict parameters so it's sort of
like how do you troubleshoot it before
you do it
not after the fact which i think is a
really important aspect of this kind of
of making stuff like this and then
we both shot way way way way too much
stuff so janessa kind of had to pick the
best
chunk and see how they would fit
together um
because she asked us to shoot maybe two
minutes and both of us
gave her about 10 minutes of stuff so i
think we made her job harder
um what are you gonna do it was really
it was it ended up being really fun to
dance around like that
yeah i think oh sorry if troy wants to
go for us
okay uh yeah so i think for us so i
guess i mainly
edited the video um i so actually
we had we had thought about doing this
concept beforehand and then
uh i had no video editing experience
and so i went and edited like another
video instead
because i wanted to make sure like i
knew stuff before going into this one
um but i guess it was like the process
of finding first of all like a video
editor where i could put in like
multiple screens and
arrange them however i wanted um and
stuff like that
and then after that it was just like a
lot of googling to figure out
how do i do this or that
and putting it all together basically
because we had sort of visually what we
wanted it to look like already mapped
out before
joy do you want to jump in on what adt
does with editing
yeah so back when we were doing our
covers um
we used to film many many times so i
think we would normally
do 9 or 10 takes per cover just like the
whole dance run it through
um which usually would take around two
hours two to three hours just for
filming like filming days are always big
days
um so if you remember the last video i
showed in the premiere we actually did
that during sunset so that's why you saw
the sky
literally change colors um and in terms
of editing
again it's the synchronization tool on
premiere pro it's definitely like
holy grail of dance editing because you
are able to sync different things up
like really easily
and i'm also like new to video editing i
just started this summer i was making
vlogs for
um this art program that was happening
with also with the arts office
so that's kind of how i was training
myself to prepare for this semester
because i knew adt was going to do a lot
of video editing
awesome thank you um so we just have
just a few minutes left
so i'm going to go with the broadest
question that's left is what is the best
setup for virtual dancing for example is
there better
to be closer to a computer mic or better
be far away to get more of your body in
the frame
um i guess i can talk about this a
little bit so for me and for us
i guess it depends on your goal so
we've been used to dancing you know full
body and having your entire body in the
frame
and like dancing in a group and all that
so this is definitely different
and i think we kind of went in with the
intention
of just you know using this kind of
frame so that which meant like our you
know face upper torso and
arms i guess and so in that case it had
it worked out well because we were
closer to the mic and basically mimicked
the zoom setup
um i think for me um what i do is i
actually have a usb mic
and i use like it has like almost a two
meter long cord so what i normally do is
i put my laptop in the corner of a room
and then i move the mic closer to where
i am teaching or standing or doing
whatever
so my voice still my voice and the music
which comes directly from the computer
are both clear
but you can also see my whole body so
that's what works best for me
i think if it's a there's a difference
between teaching
and and making for teaching um i've
actually gotten like the the best setup
is a
little wireless uh like bluetooth
headset i think so that the sound is
coming through with your with your music
so there's not a discrepancy between the
two and they're not fighting each other
um and there's a lot there's a lot of
different schools of thought like
different setups and as
as things get more advanced it becomes
easier to teach but
the hardest part for teaching is the
balance between what you're saying and
the music playing and
and being in the room in terms of
virtual dancing for making something i
100 agree with what ani was saying it's
like what is your goal
and do you want hands do you want the
whole body it's
it's the same as like setting things up
on a stage should someone be in the
center to the right to the left
what you know whatever there's all sorts
of different stuff it's it's
case by case completely different and
there's really cool stuff you can do
with the um
the virtual stuff you can get you know
you can get like a hand
right here which is really hard to do in
a proscenium theater
so you know there's there's things you
can discover that make it even cooler to
be on video it's just sort of what you
want
awesome we are at time for this panel so
i want to thank
haraz ani joy and dan for joining us and
i want to thank the audience for
such wonderful questions um feel free
everybody to put your
keep your eyes on me
i knew we were bound to be
eyes on together
[Music]
this is
keep your eyes